this is a production of Cornell
University
they're so yeah my title today is a time
for barley to go naked after 10,000
years and if there was a subtitle to
this presentation it would be the
conclusion of another man after a life
with barley and that is because I have
spent the last thirty years my
professional life working on barley and
there is a book a real book out there
this is not Photoshop called one man's
life with barley and it is a much better
book than anything I could write and
it's by Harry Harlan and he was one of
the pioneering plant explorers and
traveled the world and was responsible
for I think a lot of the vision that we
have for conservation of plant genetics
resources and so if you have a chance to
get a copy of one man's life with barley
I'd encourage you to go there let me do
sect the title a little bit here it
wasn't intended to be at all you know
sort of the kind of thing to bring
people out after lunch but first let's
just do barley and in what's barley for
those of you not familiar with it it is
hordeum vulgare subspecies vulgare you
will see it often referred to as just
hordeum vulgare but technically we
should use the subspecies because it is
completely inter fertile with its wild
ancestor which is subspecies spot Nahum
it's a diploid has a large genome size
has that sort of average number of genes
and it is a hermaphrodite and so this is
kind of all-important in the breeding
and genetics and so forth of this
organism because it's highly tolerant of
inbreeding and as a consequence we see
primarily pure line varieties throughout
the world there have been kind of on and
off attempts at hybrid production in
barley and those really haven't caught
on until recently Syngenta's been
marketing some hybrid feed Barley's in
europe with some considerable success
there is still public and private plant
breeding in the Americas and so my
colleague Mark Sorrels and students on
his project are still barley breeders
and wheat breeders and so forth at
universities we have had a much greater
presence of the private sector in
cereals breeding in the last several
years here in the Americas in the
rest of the world really then it's a
private venture and so barley and wheat
have long since gone down the road that
we've seen in the US with corn and
soybeans and other crops so let me get
to the naked part of the title here and
the naked in this case refers to the
adherence of the lemma in Pylea to the
Kari OPS's to the seed and so if they
adhere then you have what is called a
covered barley and if they don't adhere
they're not adhering you have what we'll
call a naked barley and I'm gonna use
this naked nomenclature after Takeda at
all here who are the ones who cloned
this gene and then reported in 2008
because by saying naked and covered you
just get around this real messy kind of
grammatical semantic thing because if
you want to say that a barley doesn't
have a halt is it hull-less with a - is
it Hollis with just two L's and it's
just and it's complicated and further
complicated by the fact that if that's
Hollis then what is the alternative and
its hold which can be misconstrued to
sound as though it has had its whole
removed so it's just easier to say
covered and naked I think so
hence the terms the gene abbreviation is
nude for new demand the covered form
right here where we have the adhering
lemma and palea is dominance and it is
indeed the wild and ancestral condition
and when Takeda and his group cloned
this they identified this as an ethylene
response factor it's a transcription
factor and the mechanism by which it
works is that there is or is not the
formation of a lipid layer between the
lemma and palea in the pericarp and if
the lipid forms then the lemon peleas
sticks and if the layer doesn't form
then it thrush is clean so for you folks
who are familiar with wheat and other
grains that thrush clean this is like no
surprise it's sort of like well why not
we thought all grains were that way
barley is rather unique in being a major
cereal crop of the fourth most important
in the world that actually has a tightly
adhering halt and so we'll kind of see
some of the reasons why that has
transpired so now to the ten thousand
year part of the title here so barley
originated as din so many of our other
crops and domesticated animals in the
Fertile Crescent and then you saw a
dispersal of barley from that ancestral
site and there's a couple of key traits
that are part of that domestication
syndrome and the naked covered phenotype
is is one of them
so certainly shattering or the brittle
rei'kas is characteristic of the
subspecies font name and that's that
condition have a picture of it in the
next slide here that just facilitates
seed dispersal and so you definitely
want the non shattering non brittle
rei'kas in bulk are the domesticated
sort spot name is a two row for those of
you not familiar with Barley's two row
means you have a single row of kernels
on either side of the spike and so
that's a fertile florida at every rekha
snowed and if you're a six row then you
have three so the ancestral form is two
and the post domestication form is six
the spot name the ancestral sort has an
adhering halt I said that was a wild
type that dominant allele and there are
adhering and non adhering halls within
volgar and in terms of growth habit
something we really won't get into today
but that is very near and dear to my
heart then you have just winter annuals
in the hordeum spontaneity have winter
facultative and spring annual types
present in the derive so that of course
gives us this kind of apparent situation
and we all know that appearances can be
deceiving
that'll be my only political illusion
today but one of them is it seems that
we have much greater diversity over here
in volgar than we do in the spot name
but in fact of course it's quite the
reverse because we had a number of
evolutionary bottlenecks along the way
where we've lost allelic diversity in
vulgare and so that is a very active
averse area of research is to go back
and start to try to bring in our mind
some of those alleles that may have been
lost in the domestication process this
is a picture of the brittle reyes and if
you've ever never encountered this
you've probably encountered brittle
rei'kas in other wild grassy weed
species and you walk through those
fields in the summer and half the field
winds up in your socks and so it's an
excellent seed dispersal mechanism and
of course just the thing we don't want
in agriculture because we want those
seeds to hang on into their seeds to
remain on the head as long as possible
what's kind of interesting about the BTR
genes there's two of them is that both
of them are loss of functions there's
deletions and that leads to a loss of
function of the abscission layer there
vrs one which is the two row 6 row is
also a loss of function situation also
due in this case to multiple different
deletions inside the same gene nud the
whole advance is also a loss of function
in this case the whole gene is gone just
takeda and all revealed that in all the
exceptions that they looked at the gene
has just disappeared 17 KB of it plus
some flanking sequence they have then
generated some new mutants and then kept
up with other ways of generating the
same phenotype growth habits again not
the topic of today's seminar but loss of
function deletions and flowering time
there are also loss of function deletion
so it's just this kind of long list of
these domestication traits being loss of
function and that kind of gives us
something to think about
if you think about some of the simplest
applications of genome editing how many
other things are there out there that
you might want to go into and then just
generate loss of function mutants with
and come up with target phenotypes
so or some paper that just came out
recently here in Nature Genetics by
masher at all and they report on doing a
lot of nice genomics on some paleo
botanical remains of barley at Masada in
Israel and it they you know there's a
lot to see about this barley including
the fact that it looks very much like
Barley's we might see today in
fluorescence might be just a tad shorter
but one thing about it it was still
covered in so 4,000 years post
domestication in that end of the world
there was still covered barley now
Takeda it all argued that there was
probably a monophyletic origin of the
naked tree and that that domestication
event happened about 8,000 years ago so
they're not sure exactly where this
happened but we've got a couple of hints
as to where that may have been and we'll
come to that in just a second here
so you have this domestication moment
you have the Middle East and then you
have this just explosive dissemination
of Agriculture and animal husbandry
across Europe and Asia and that's
proceeding at a rate of maybe about a
mile per year and so that may seem kind
of slow if you can walk 20 miles in a
day but you know when you think about
actually then planting harvesting a crop
and then convincing your neighbor to
plant and harvest that crop then mile
progressions every year are actually
pretty impressive so quickly barley
moves out across the landscape and this
migration and specialization then leads
to things that come back to the halt and
so I've kind of told this little history
here of barley and then I'm coming into
this sort of migration thing to tell you
a little bit about Europe and a little
bit about Asia and then some alternate
uses of barley and holes in those two
environments so in Europe you had a an
ever-increasing focus on barley for its
use in the manufacture of beer
not to say there weren't uses also for
human food and animal feeding and so
forth but principally for beer
and principally the forms that were used
were barley with holes and those tended
to be spring growth habits and they
tended to be two rows so in this little
cartoon here you see a representation of
the Reinheitsgebot and this is the
German purity law this is barley here
this is hops this is water and that's
yeast course they didn't know about
yeast at that time that was sort of
added later but the argument was and not
the argument the law was and is that the
beer could only contain those three and
four elements and it did not contain
adjuncts so this is an angry wheat and
angry maize and an angry rice up here
who cannot participate in the beer as
they are want to do in American Standard
lagers so when I first learned about
this as a as a barley breeder I thought
wow that is just you know another
example of people really knowing good
beer and so there's this German brewing
tradition and you'd think wow they had
this law that just sort of embodied
their their knowledge about beer and in
fact it turns out that it was probably
this law was there for a number of other
reasons one is it protected drinkers
from high prices it banned the use of
wheat in beer so that more bread could
be made and so the fact of the matter
was the the beer drinkers were using up
the available wheat and that wasn't
leaving enough food for the rest of
society and so they said well hey make
the beer out of the coarser grain and
then leave the wheat out there for
nutrition now if you're half of i'ts an
enthusiast or something you'll know that
there was still a tradition of brewing
with wheat in Germany but the other
piece there was that unscrupulous ruiers
were adding toxic and even
hallucinogenic ingredients as
preservatives or flavorings in their
beers and so you know that's a whole
frontier that will continuously be
explored I think as we see an increase
in craft brewing and leaked legalized
cannabis and so those two elements will
probably be coming together and we may
be promulgating a new Reinheitsgebot
here too
that sort of thing from happening again
so meanwhile a very different sort of
scenario has unfolded in in Asia and
particularly in Central and East Asia
their barley assumes a role in food and
so it's particularly its role in food
was most notable in the Himalayan
plateau and so this gentleman's a
tibetan buddhist monk and he's preparing
to eat some some pup which is in this
case prepared from a toasted barley
flour and that's mixed with yak butter
and green tea and so it's a very
nutritious material that can be very
easily prepared there are very high
elevations not a tremendous amount of
infrastructure required to prepare this
food and so a recent paper in science by
chen at all actually argues that barley
in fact allowed for the settlement of
the himalayan plateau that you simply
could not have moved into those higher
elevations had it not been for this very
early maturing cereal and also in their
case a cereal that was naked so that it
could be immediately consumed so you may
ask well you know why can't she just eat
barley so you you could but that's lemma
those dilemma and paleo that hall
consists of cellulose hemicellulose and
lignin and it's not palatable it is
insoluble dietary fiber and wears a lot
of us need fiber in our diets we
generally don't need insoluble dietary
fiber and so it's just much easier to
not have it there anybody eat barley
today yeah today I mean white bean in
every day John okay so we'll talk about
that later but okay anybody barley this
wheat oh my god that's why we come out
from the west to the east and we
proselytize our crops yeah okay
so was it a pearl barley perhaps that
you have if anybody so pearl what is
pearl barley pearl barley is barley that
has been mechanically abraded to remove
the hull and so if you have a naked
barley you don't have to pearl it but if
purling
this grinding process in that grinding
process removes dilemma and palea and it
also removes a little bit of testa a
little bit of pericarp a little bit of
alley around and that's enough to make
your barley no longer be considered a
whole grain legally so whether or not
you're losing you know phytonutrients
that's a whole other topic of discussion
here but legally you cannot call that a
whole grain so not the tibetans were
worried about whole grain or not but
they selected for naked and incidentally
populations where there is high
consumption of barley have the lowest
incidence of colorectal cancers of any
societies so soluble dietary fiber is a
good thing also has a number of other
positive effects that we'll come to in
just a little bit this is just a quick
walk through of a Japanese grocery store
showing a whole sample of barley
products that you know readily
accessible now as you got into China and
Japan and Korea barley was an important
part of the culinary nutrition culture
but of course rice was was preeminent
there and so barley has kind of to my
understanding a subsidiary role and
sometimes a very sort of a negative
perception role in those areas where it
is viewed as the famine food so it was
what you ate only when you didn't have
rice and so that's been kind of a
psychological barrier that people have
been having to work for so that kind of
brings us to what's barley used for and
you know what's implied so what do we
have here malt in the making so the
process of melting barley is a process
of controlled germination and this is
the result of the end of the first phase
and into the second phase and so you've
gone through what's called the Steep
where the barley is alternatively soaked
and then exposed to air and then it's
allowed to germinate and these are the
little reutlitz that are emerging and
the incipient chute is actually forming
in under the whole but you can't see it
in this case because it is a barley that
that has a hole and once that
germination process is accomplished then
the barley is killed and
depending on the temperature and
duration of that killing process you
come out with a range of malts which
then go into our beers and so you have
everything from pale malts all the way
to roasted malts at the other extreme
the so you might ask the question well
why barley why don't we do this
anything else and the answer is you can
do it to anything else and there are now
Moulton companies that are moulting
other grains besides barley notable is
one in Colorado called Grouse malting
and their monstrous twill ax is an
expert in molting things like chia and
buckwheat and other grains then for
celiacs who would like to have molted
grains going into a beer but why malted
barley for beer
so malted barley is is like a perfect
little nutrition capsule for yeast and
in the process of fermentation what
we're after is ethanol and so we're
harnessing the yeast to give its give us
its excretion so that we can have
ethanol and flavor and if you wanted to
design the perfect little nutrient
capsule for yeast it's going to be that
malted barley kernel so that's why of
all the cereals that are out there
barley provides the optimum balance of
starch sugars proteins and that can
carry on the fermentation process and
allow yeast to do for us what we want it
to do so what about barley foods so
barley foods today account for a
negligible portion of the total barley
that's produced in the United States and
consumed certainly less than 10% however
the FDA says that if you incorporate
barley at a specified amount into your
diet you will reduce your risk of heart
disease you'll reduce your risk of type
2 diabetes and you will achieve satiety
achieving satiety alone is something
that could be a goal for many of us
right just to sort of be cool and happy
with wherever you are so just eat your
barley and that's where it will take you
so what accounts for this this these
wonderful properties it's it is a
soluble
dietary fiber fraction called beta
glucan and beta glucan is found in cell
walls throughout the barley endosperm
beta glucans found in appreciable
quantities only in oatmeal otherwise and
in oats and in oatmeal marks orals isn't
here so I can really knock oats but in
oats it's only found in the outer layer
of the endosperm and that's why oats
make that horrible gluey icky thing when
you cook them because the beta glucan is
just sort of right out there you cook
barley flakes and you'll have actual
integrity of each flake but you'll still
have the same level of beta glucan so as
soon as the FDA comes out with this RDA
and there was research prior to that
then of course what do we do is plant
breeders well if a little bit is good a
lot would be better right so all of a
sudden every breeding program is out
there going well let's breed for high
beta glucan and so they've been in fact
very successful in doing so your average
barley a moulting barley will contain
about four to five percent grain beta
glucan that's beta glucan and the
malting barley is broken down by beta
glucan ace endogenous beta glucan aces
during the malting process and in fact
brewers want low levels of beta glucan
in their beer otherwise it becomes
viscous and causes processing problems
so on the food on the other hand you say
Wow
beta glucan I want this in my food and
so breeders have been very successful
even over the last 10 years in
developing high beta glucan Barley's and
they now have them up to say 15% if you
were to eat one bowl of barley flakes
made from a barley that's four percent
beta glucan that will satisfy your RDA
these are barley breads made with 40
percent barley flour barley has gluten
in the sense that it will Alicia eight
elicits a negative response in a celiac
but it does not have gluten in for a
baker in the sense that its dough does
not have strength and elasticity so you
you're about your maximum blend is going
to be about 40 percent barley
going into a wheat blend but if you have
two slices of bread made with a barley
that's about four to five percent beta
glucan you will meet your RDA a sandwich
so what happens if you eat 15% beta
glucan gastrointestinal distress of epic
room-clearing proportions so what then
why do I do this so plant breeders be
careful once you start going down this
road of selecting four more there are
sometimes unanticipated pleiotropic
effects right so the so what's that has
led to is kind of a schism in barley
breeding if you will where if you have a
whole-grain model you just can get by
with four to five percent beta glucan
you don't need that high stuff if
however you're on a model where you want
to extract or fraction ate the beta
glucan and put that onto a Twinkie or a
cheeto and call it health food then you
want to go for the high stuff so there's
sort of two different markets out there
so feed 80% of the barley used in the
world today is used to feed animals
mostly ruminant animals but I don't
didn't have a nice picture of cow so I
picture of these pigs and these pigs in
fact are in a barley field you see in
the distance there that is a barley
field and this farmer just unleashes
them into barley fields and then moves
the electric fence a couple hundred feet
every day and the pigs are happier than
if they were in clover you know the
expression like a pig in clover so
they're very happy they're just eating
this this green barley as they go along
and that's the residue of the barley
straw below but most of the barley in
the world today is fed to animals and
about 80% and in the u.s. until about
maybe 20 years ago and we'll see the
graph of this and talk about that in a
sec that was also the case here now
we've had a complete flip so that almost
all the barley grown in the United
States is used for melting and brewing a
little bit for food and a very little
bit for feed but the feed markets are
essential in my opinion because if you
don't have a feed market you
have no safety net for your grain barley
is has excellent feeding properties and
a lot of research you know has it
confirms that and sort of brings us to
this point here so we'll talk about that
research in a moment once we've talked
about how we got to this so what do you
think this is US barley acreage millions
of acres so if you follow this graph
back to 1986 which is when I started my
job it's even more obviously linear so
it's a cause-and-effect relationship the
longer pat breeds barley in Oregon the
more the barley acres in America go down
once it's established
god bless the tenure system right now so
there's a number of reasons why this has
happened and before we go into you know
sort of this slope of despondency here
let's talk about this little plateau of
encouragement over here and what that's
due to so little plateau of
encouragement is due to places like New
York State amongst others where barley
acreage is actually increasing and why
is it increasing its increasing because
of the craft brewing craft distilling
and craft melting industries and then in
addition here you've legislated and that
is further driven barley acres and so
the craft industry is what is driving
this the slight increase but it's really
going to be a tapering phenomena because
there's only so much barley that those
industries can absorb for example if
you're running a craft moulting
enterprise 10-ton batch is a pretty
respectable batch size a lot of them are
smaller than that to run a 10-ton batch
system requires about 500 acres of
barley high yielding barley so it
doesn't take a whole lot to meet those
needs and so you have the Sunoco
facility opening up here in New York
State that's going to have I think six
10 tonne errs chomping on barley and so
that's going to lead to an increase in
acres but in terms of overall impact
it's still a couple of thousand acre
we'll probably feed that machine so what
caused that decline so there's a there's
a whole there's a number of factors that
contributed to that decline but they are
all feeding into this sort of story
where we're headed here and anybody in
here ever played pit what was your
favorite commodity just say barley okay
it's a supposed to be the Chicago Board
of Trade game and so you're pretending
that you're down in the pit and you're
calling out commodities and you've got
pork belly pork belly and you got barley
barley barley barley barley is one of
the cards but barley is no longer traded
on the Chicago hoard and so that sort of
shows where it's at look at where barley
is going here the largest importer of
barley if you had any assailed by Saudi
Arabia followed by China so China is a
definite beer market there Australia and
Canada dominate that market Saudi Arabia
is primarily a traditional livestock use
area and a lot of racing camels are
barley not a particularly stable market
the racing camel in an era of declining
revenues in some of these countries but
what are we seeing we're seeing a
situation where barley is actually
priced after corn it's a function of
corn prices and so typically barley is
priced at 80% of the price of corn corn
prices now are incredibly depressed if
you know to follow commodities markets
their feed prices are incredibly low at
the moment if barley is 80 percent of
something incredibly low which is true
in conventional feed barley production
you lose money from the get-go so that's
a reason people don't want to have feed
barley out there why is there wire feed
barley prices so low when the research
confirms that probably the feeding value
of barley can be the same or superior to
corn in some feeding applications a
couple of things have happened which are
so much bigger than anything that we can
address is plant breeders are scientists
that we just have to mention them and
move on so one of them are federal farm
programs we have a program of very
indirect price supports in in the US and
one of them is called
revenue assurance where you can
essentially ensure your crop if you have
the right crop to a value that you know
will allow you to generate a stable
income you can't do that for barley
secondly you have a situation where
you've had changes in the confined
animal feeding industry so now you have
enormous operations for consolidated
dairies and feed Lots and even in Oregon
these folks find it cheaper to bring in
Midwestern corn and unit trains than to
buy barley from the farm next door so
that that leads to a situation where you
then have no market for feed even if you
do have a place to actually be selling
it and then you have sort of you know
kind of the final clincher in this which
is you have incredibly successful plant
breeders in the Midwest breeding corn
and soybeans and corn and soybeans along
with global warming have moved
increasingly northward and westward and
occupied what were barley acres in
Minnesota and North Dakota that corn and
soybeans happens to be GMO which is
neither you know here nor there I think
in terms of that effect on barley but it
does play into the story that we're
going to come to in a sec out in our
neck of the woods we don't have a whole
lot of GMO corn our soybeans at this
point but we do have herbicide resistant
wheat we have imidazole and resistant
wheat generated as a mutation not as a
GMO but the consequence of that is that
herbicide is applied to ground where
formerly barley was a rotation crop that
herbicide persists for 12 months and the
barley can't follow in the rotation so
between all of those factors then we've
seen barley acres plummet and you know
what do you do well since I've worked on
barley for 30 years I don't want to see
it disappear I don't want to see it just
become a relic crop but I do think in
addition to just wanting things to
persist because they're cool that there
are reasons that barley can be
advantageous for farmers it's early
maturing two weeks earlier than wheat
uses about 80 20 percent less nitrogen
than wheat but has all the same standard
green infrastructure processors it's
absolutely essential for molting for
food processors the same infrastructure
you use for milling grinding
cracking for the feed industry rations
and delivery can be the same consumers
gives you a range of beverages
heart-healthy foods
in some new sensory attributes in your
diet so I think there's a lot of good
reasons to have barley out there in our
lives but it's it's hard to convince
people sometimes that that's necessary
and so what I've got now is to shift
gears a little bit and I've kind of told
you this barley story and use you as a
bit of a focus group because we're
having a planning grant session at the
end of this month and it's funded by the
NIF o REI so that's the organic research
branch of nipa and a planning grant is
where you kind of get people together to
say do we really want to write a full
grant proposal on this thing and the
proposal is about the release testing
and development of public sector
multi-use naked barley varieties so
that's where I come back to this topic
here this is barley here winter barley
growing next to a GMO corn and on a
per-unit efficiency basis this thing is
going to produce a whole lot more than
this one over here but in this
particular case this is not a comparison
because that is a GMO corn which this
particular panel will not allow so the
question is then okay we come into the
organic panel what could we do that
would capitalize on the kinds of
research that they might be interested
in funding and why so the first thing is
is that we're looking at market
simplification here so if you have a
naked barley in theory it could be used
for all three uses okay you could vault
with it you could eat it and you could
use it as feed so a farmer currently if
they raise malt barley has barley with a
halt can they sell it as food if they
have excess protein no you'd have to
grind the whole off can they sell it for
feed no they're going to be at a loss if
you're selling if you're growing a naked
barley can you get a mold stirrer brewer
to use it and the answer is no because
they're not familiar with moulting and
brewing with Naked Barley's can you get
a feeder to use it you're going to have
to go uncover someone so in the convince
large-scale commodity markets there is
not room to pursue this multi-use good
idea hence the idea of saying ok the
organic sector may be receptive to a
newer idea and thus that could be a
platform where we could seek to get some
acceptance some adoption and then let it
diffuse out from there some attributes
will be that it has to be naked first
and foremost it has to have modest grain
beta-glucan you can't have 15% erse
because the Brewers won't use it it's
got to have normal starch there's waxy
and high amylose starch types we want to
avoid those you're gonna have to have
yield and adaptation in your target
environments and you're going to want to
have some entry interesting sensory
attributes that you know big people want
to eat this stuff you can kind of follow
a maximum that's been around there for a
long time which that a good malt barley
is a good feed and a good feed barley if
you don't believe that these are ice
cream sandwiches made out of barley
cookies with a barley malt ice cream
sensory attributes fiber flavor calories
okay so what are we saying here that in
this situation we are looking for the
elimination of the hall after 10,000
years it's time to just go naked and
then say okay let's focus on this
particular aspect of barley so why go
you know organic anybody in here done on
farm organic research organic breeding
scale plots can be some challenges right
particularly weed control amongst other
things and certainly in our environment
our University farm has a very limited
certified organic acreage they can't put
in really representative rotations to
properly encourage fertility and weed
control and so as a consequence you get
into this kind of weird input
replacement and endless weed Patrol so
this was an organic increased block of a
new naked barley of ours
it's called buck okay buck naked barley
tough there's some additional work there
we with the organic route again because
the idea was hey there'd be perhaps
receptiveness to this concept we also
struck out with the conventional panels
we had some really elegant
genomic selection models for human food
we created resource I'll mention in a
second here but as I told the graduate
students earlier today never remain
bitter about reviews but just memorize
them and repeat them because someday
that person is going to be in the room
and then they'll understand the mortal
wound that they inflicted on a fellow
scientist so we got a review from one of
these genomic selection proposals and
this individual says you know hey I can
hardly imagine barley as being the
poster child for good nutrition so it's
like get some fiber dude you know anyway
so what can we do to make this happen so
the first and fundamental thing you may
go well wait a second barley has had a
hole on it for 10,000 years because of
the brewing tradition in that hole is
absolutely critical so this is barley
moulting with a hole on it because of a
process called loitering and loitering
is after you have taken your malt and
you have boiled it and added your
bittering hops then that liquid called
the wort is then passed through the
grain bed and the process known as
sparging and moved off to the fermenter
that grain that spent malt at the bottom
of that tank then is a natural
filtration system par excellence and
that's why holes have persisted until
today so you ask the question how can we
get past that and it is with a
technology called mash filtration
membranes and pressure use a whole lot
less water and a whole lot less energy
so many breweries in Europe are Team
Asheville tur breweries they went that
way
simply to reduce energy and water usage
in the US Alaskan amber you may be
familiar with as a mash filter quit
brewery and we've got three or so craft
breweries in the US including one that
just built a new brewery in Bend Oregon
Krux fermentation project that is all
mash filter based so we do have ways now
that you can move a naked barley malt so
this is naked barley malting down here
directly into a mash filtration system
those of you that are barley people one
of the key parameters that we work on
for moulting is something called malt
extract both extract numbers of a good
barley with a whole are typically around
eighty to eighty three percent in a
naked barley that malt extract can be at
88 or 89 percent what does that mean
that means more beer per unit of malt
put into the brewery so the Brewers can
be very attracted by that what else is a
whole bringing to beer astringency
microorganisms things that you may not
particularly want in some styles of beer
so I think that we have some advantages
there for the brewer what about four
foods so this was at a recent event in
in Portland called the plant variety
showcase it's a thing called the
culinary breeding Network and so this is
a local Baker who's prepared a series of
breads from different barley varieties
because the point of this was to
showcase the foods made from a range of
barley varieties and pepper varieties
and squash varieties and so forth and so
yes you can do it you can make delicious
breads of all sorts and styles with
different types of barley up to about
that 40% inclusion rate and that could
be exactly the same barley that went to
your malt house could go into those lows
and better yet the malt that you made
out of that naked barley can also feed
back into your baking system and that
brings in a whole other palette of
flavors aromas and sensories finally the
organic feed sector at least by the
advertisements we see they all have a
much better time at their lives than
some people and some other sorts of
operations and so optimistically yes we
can see whole grain barley is moving
into various animal feeding regimes
because that that safety net is
absolutely essential as the third leg on
a stool if you will for marketing
barley crop so now we come to the plant
breeding part of this you know I'll
finally here in the last you know seven
minutes or whatever that we have and so
you know after thirty years of writing
grant proposals to brewing companies and
NSF panels and other people about
different aspects of our crop finally
this is like the first time I get to
write one it's just sort of carte
blanche and you go like all the way back
to those just like sort of fundamental
things about what you do with the
breeding program and one of them is you
know what are your target environments
who are your target users out there what
are the target traits are gonna work on
what kind of germ plasm are you gonna
use how are you gonna advance that germ
plasm what is the basis of your
selection and what kind of varieties are
you gonna release I'm just gonna kind of
walk you through these real quickly and
then open it up for some opportunities
for discussion and perspective here so
the target environments that we have are
the Pacific Northwest the Upper Midwest
and the Northeast that would be New York
here with mark Sorrels and this is our
colleague Kevin Smith in Minnesota why
these regions well we had plant breeders
who are interested in this we have
processors who are perhaps early
adopters of some technologies we have
consumers who are interested in a
variety of foods and then the
anticipation is that we would see a
subsequent diffusion out into other
geographic areas and into the
conventional sector as well our target
audiences here's one that we can have
cannot neglect
I don't think and this is a very good
friend of the families and we had our
one of our food barley composites
growing in her garden and so she invites
her friends over and we have this sort
of little harvest party these people had
never grown a cereal they had never
processed a cereal they had never
prepared a cereal that was two hours old
and so we harvested this barley took
over our threshing machine harvested
that prepared it and had a barley
tabbouleh made from something they
harvested hours before we hit 10 people
out there who went and told 10 other
people who told 10 other people about
how barley was something you could grow
at home and it was really cool and it
was good for you and so there's an
important piece there but of equal and
greater importance are their children
and so moving barley into schools in
through various science and education
pieces and so we call this sort of the
learners
they're gonna have very small acreage
things we have artists and these are the
folks down at your farmers markets who
may have in the tens of acres craft
maybe the hundreds of acres and then the
industrial sort of regional folks maybe
a thousand acres you know
levels and so there's different
audiences we're going to be targeting
here and I think we need different kinds
of germ plasm for those people and
there's going to be different sorts of
traits that we target everything has to
be homozygous recessive I think we just
have to have naked varley's molting and
brewing quality is something that
already exists we have the American malt
barley Association it has guidelines we
need some allowance for higher malt
extract they're not going to complain
about that but maybe just a little bit
higher beta glucan maybe a 200 instead
of a you know under a hundred where they
are now not talking scary levels of beta
glucan in beer food quality is really
very simple as long as you don't bring
in novel starch types or high beta
glucan our life as barley breeders could
almost be as simple as that of corn
breeders we just breed for yield we just
want more of this good naked stuff
growing per egg per unit acre now of
course you've got all the additional
challenges of what's going to make yield
under an organic system but it's yield
that you're after in feed quality I
think it's yield ultimately once you get
greater market penetration then you'll
start to see I think some feed back into
the breeding programs that says we need
that flavor attribute we need this kind
of kernel hardness we need something
else but we don't have those signals now
growth habit I'd like to see facultative
in spring Barley's because of climate
change but winners are okay two rows are
preferred but six rows are okay colors a
whole pallet is okay if you're breeding
for conventional markets right now
you'll recognize that this is not the
way that you can breed for large
commodity producers they'll tell you
what color what's specific level of a
hundred and one traits and so you're
much more confined and defined in your
breeding scheme the germplasm basis
we've got some ongoing naked barley
programs and we have something called
the naked barley doubled haploid
composite we've got a germ plasm release
on this that we're writing up right now
so it'll come out but the seed is
available if anybody would like to get
this it's 900 double haploids derived
from about 35 process amongst 28 parents
40 different grandparents that we source
from 14 different breeding programs and
selections we created this resource in
anticipation of doing this genomic
selection program grant didn't get
funded we're in a hurry had to harvest
we said the hell with it drove the
combine perpendicular to all the plots
took us an hour so we just mixed
everything together and so they're all
in there and we've send this synthesis
cools public breeding programs private
breeding programs mark Sorel's your
colleague here has started a naked
barley program based on the naked barley
blood composite it's got Springs witters
facultative two rows six rows whites
blacks Browns etc so there's a whole
range of material in there some very
interesting things to do with schools in
terms of natural selection versus
implemented selection germ plasm and
advance we've got this all the double
haploids that are in this composite we
still have them we have the original and
remnant seat so we have all 900 of those
my breeding program is a hundred percent
double haploid based so we're producing
new double haploids from cycles with
naked malt Marley's that have come out
of a Canadian program and will pursue a
collaborative development and testing of
those but segregating generations will
be available to those who would want
them at some point the basis of
selection for that composite you can
simply go real easy Bob Allard published
this beautiful paper in the late 70s
about evolutionary plant breeding and he
showed that just by planting the same
mixture year after year for his 30 years
at UC Davis he had the same rate of gain
as his colleague Charley Schuyler who
was running a pedigree breeding program
and Charley was a pretty good breeder so
natural selection bulk breeding is not
to be denied but there's directed
phenotypic selection genotypic selection
there's a lot of enthusiasm I would say
this is probably a focus of genomic
selection internationally and so there
are thoughts that we might implement
something to some extent in a program
like this and
who's the plant breeder professional or
participatory this is a participatory
program we have going on with two folks
in Eastern Oregon this is Seth and his
dad Brad and they're working with us to
develop a variety in their case of
double haploid barley that will
specifically feed into their estate
molding system so finally let's come to
germ plasm release what sorts of
varieties will we be releasing here so
you know I lay it all out here I'm an
open source person I get really
concerned about tight control over
germplasm resources and so I support at
least the concept of the open seed
source initiative and we have the
variety full pint which then we released
underneath the auspices of that
organization we've been using germ plasm
releases we have a particularly stuffy
tech transfer office in my University
you could quote me saying that I've
called them worse sometimes but when
they won't let you release something as
a variety you can release it as a germ
plasm through the journal of plant
registrations that gets the material out
into the public domain and people can
access it the problem being that you
can't sell classes of certified seed
finally we've made some headway and
except here varieties I had the weirdest
thing this whole trip has been weird I'd
lost I couldn't get here yesterday so I
had this time frame thing in my travel
and then the spell check quit working in
my PowerPoint and I haven't found a way
to renew that but anyways we've got
public varieties with no PvP so that
gives you an option there the revenue
thing is an interesting one because our
office will argue as many that hey we
need to mine our breeding programs they
need to become self-sustaining if we're
going to have public sector breeding it
needs to pay for itself if we use the
current seed royalties we have a
thousand acres is something that
optimistically we would have in one of
those target growing regions that would
generate you about two thousand dollars
a year the university would take 1/3 of
that if you took your thousand acres and
convinced your growers that they
self-assess on the amount of grain
produced then you'd start seeing some
serious money or even some percentage
thereof so I think that if you want to
see this kind of breeding generator
revenue you're going to have to
look for some other funding model other
than what we currently have so with all
that Marley world is where we try to
keep in touch with the world please have
a look at us thanks to the many people
who have worked on the barley crew past
and present and brought to you by these
various funding agencies who have all
given us funding over the years without
restriction and all of our germ plasm
and data are in the public domain
if it is not in t3 it's only because we
just haven't gotten around to posting it
yet thank you very much for this
opportunity for disease susceptibility
in their sense yeah so the question was
is there dis disease issues by going to
so we are not a concern so that is not
something
so I don't want to say no
we have not seen in this usage you do
have to take extra care in threshing and
processing that green
condition breaks and you could ask the
question why the white was the Masada
barley returning opinion
they're expecting and they probably made
some dinner but they were also indicated
some advantages in rulership modern
support persistence
you get a mesh focus set up can that be
used with covered party or is basically
you know traditional setup works at
every dependability say yes efficient
was mesh filtration they were being used
widely today in fact all with cover
partners so what it does is instead of
making a kind of course of course but if
you're also getting more out of a
textured and instead of having that fine
powder feminine 10% and cellulose which
isn't getting anything it could be a
hundred or start
other question is
now Bali has three layers 72
is usually sometimes people but you know
the question related to the structure
structure before they see the element
layers have an effect not be responsible
for the fact that it is the paper so I
would hazard a that's a good position
starting because it's not just the sheer
lovin that inside eternity to find
important is that higher included these
higher than amazed by her health
attendants perhaps but it's the balance
of course across plus
so do know that gene expression the
algorithm with signals from the interior
information accounts for one enzyme
activity
I can answer the question
it's very different to select dirty with
resistance like some pliers another
possibly exactly yes oh yes and Skeet
Ulrich who is the reader in Washington
State's now retired started educational
program to target the same teens
the successful Cafferty is clearing at
work on and they are the processing
signals so the question is that plus or
minus in the systems
the best solution also in Australia now
nice
in the northwest application they would
be Sonique
completion without the use of herbicides
particularly
Australia they needed an additional
website in order to do some people
unfortunately I guess that s where the
science is one which means rather than
all resistant so it's not sustainable
alternative
so right now the challenge we've had so
practice time we convince a current
grower of barley cover garment focused
on first thing negative this is for the
market and so in fact the first phase of
this proposed project and putting
together would be to produce large semi
commercial nuts
so that those artisan and industrial
users can access and not be a party to
the commercial bolts the whistle gears
commercial foods and get those coming to
the marketplace it's not that
unfortunately I don't think it's just
the music system that's working
production in western is not a penalty
so the top yielder and our breeding
program
the last two years has been indeed and
so he was feeding the mr. Bartlett's
Wiggles and the halt accounts for about
ten percent
so how do you ever have a naked party
take anybody mystical and then how do
you make a I turned it into a naked yes
so naked part is how do you get naked
Marley so you're simply saying is
contain fat rasa in everyone accelerate
that process the teens on other parts of
seven days so it's not some super
chromatic region there's no that I know
like my other jeans around it really
carefully
it's a pretty quick conversion program
we've done some of those kinds of
projects and that's how we got the new
gene into CRISPR probably not going to
be permitted by
since they need it's not just this kind
of real simple plug-and-play system in
this department but his team under the
pretty decent candidate because you
could completely find induced mutants
have been identified as specifically do
lead to a loss of function where the
scenes so we've got to be able to
you've got a collaborative experiment
ongoing just assuming it related to this
question so that when you makin a tea
party you oughta try to above them that
you said that didn't good-looking that
granny D is that cursive letter time
even the desert entity divers currently
they have so a problem so in this unit
but the composite that I mentioned that
then forty parents te or so those who
are India parties source from different
Greek programs around so Eastwood
fingers crossed
then we have diversity and other
positions in the genome recording to
include them all we are kind of
monophyletic in there's probably a
single origin that that original
mutation that led to the deletion
routine so there could be things right
in the vicinity
and so that's where a couple of quick
speeds are in a basket or at 70 Jill
another turn pleasant to see what the
parties were hiding random useful
discriminatory mechanisms
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu